Allora, adesso se potete trovare un posto dove stare in piedi e adesso Bante cercherà di autoriprendersi con il computer.
Ok, molto bene.
Quindi, assicurati di sentirvi in equilibrio, ben radicati.
Poi, appoggiatevi verso l'alto della testa.
E poi sollevandosi dalla sommità del capo, allungandosi.
Cominciate a rilassare la fronte.
Gli occhi andando in basso, sfocati.
Gli occhi sono rivolti verso il basso, non focalizzati.
Rilassate la mascella.
Lips together, teeth apart.
Le labbra sono unite mentre i denti sono separati.
Le spalle.
Potete anche un po' strizzarle, se volete.
E le tue mani unite in fronte o da un lato, non importa, qualsiasi cosa sia comoda.
E potete tenere le mani intrecciate davanti oppure lasciate sui fianchi, come vi risulta più comodo non ha importanza.
L'esercizio dura una decina di minuti, se sentite un po' di vertigini sedetevi.
Prendendo atto della postura.
Ben radicati, in equilibrio.
Con l'energia che scorre nella colonna e vi rende ben eretti.
E tutto il resto del corpo è lasciato ben rilassato.
E ora portate l'attenzione alle piante dei piedi.
Che cosa avvertite lì?
Potete isolare la sensazione di pressione?
Riuscite a isolare la sensazione di pressione?
Sentite che cosa avvertite rispetto al senso di calore oppure di frescura?
E quindi rispetto anche alle sensazioni che fanno sì che voi vi accorgiate di essere in piedi.
La durezza del suolo, del terreno, oppure un senso di morbidezza dato da un tappeto.
E cosa avvertite rispetto alle sensazioni neutre?
Just becoming more aware of how all the sensations are continuously arising and passing away.
Avvertendo, diventando sempre più consapevoli man mano di come le sensazioni arrivano e poi scompaiono.
E riconoscendo che le sensazioni arrivano, se le vogliamo o no, non sono sotto il nostro controllo diretto.
e anche rendendosi conto di come queste sensazioni si presentano non sono sotto il nostro controllo, arrivano per conto proprio.
E prendendo tutto il tempo necessario avvertiamo cosa
Cosa sentiamo nella parte restante del corpo?
E anche riconoscendo quei luoghi dove non ci sono sensazioni particolari.
Quando risalendo lungo il corpo, arrivate all'addome, riuscite ad avvertire il movimento dato dal respiro?
C'è forse della tensione?
Risalendo, arrivando allo stomaco, alla zona dello stomaco, avvertite il respiro lì?
Arrivando al torace, vi avvertite per caso il respiro?
C'è della tensione?
E avvertite il battito del cuore.
Le spalle sono ancora rilassate.
The jaw.
The brow.
When you get to the scalp, scan it like you did the soles of your feet.
What can you feel there?
When you get to the scalp, the top of the head,
Ah, ok.
Quando arrivate proprio alla sommità del capo, che cosa avvertite?
Ora, senza muovere gli occhi, lancia l'attenzione fuori.
Senza muovere gli occhi, rivolgete l'attenzione verso l'esterno.
Alle forme, ai colori che sono di fronte a voi.
Ai suoni, se ce ne sono.
All'atmosfera della stanza in cui vi trovate.
Quindi adesso l'attenzione è completamente rivolta all'esterno.
E ora, allo stesso tempo, prestate attenzione a che cosa c'è dentro di noi.
Sia all'interno che all'esterno.
Questa è la bubba della nostra conoscenza.
Questa è la bolla della nostra consapevolezza.
Questo è il nostro piccolo mondo, il nostro universo.
E noi siamo sempre al suo centro.
E quindi tanto vale rilassarsi.
Just relax into this present moment, wide awake.
rilassandoci nel momento presente ma ben svegli e vigili.
Relaxing, dwelling in the present moment, wide awake,
Rilassandoci, dimorando nel momento presente, ben svegli.
Possiamo lasciare andare tutti i pensieri rispetto all'ottenimento di qualche cosa.
Quando siamo in modo di raggiungere, stiamo sempre facendo qualcosa ora per qualche risultato futuro.
Quando cerchiamo di ottenere qualcosa, stiamo facendo qualcosa adesso per ottenere qualcosa nel futuro.
Ma in questa modalità del semplice essere, questo è il risultato.
rilassandoci dimorando nel momento presente ben svegli in questa modalità non esiste futuro non stiamo andando da nessuna parte siamo sempre arrivati
Stiamo sempre arrivando.
Rilassandoci, dimorando nel momento presente, ben svegli.
In questa modalità non abbiamo reazioni, non abbiamo risposte particolari.
Siamo in uno stato di recettività.
E così, in questo modo, non abbiamo bisogno di presentare qualcuno, un corpo, una personalità.
Possiamo essere anonimi.
Relaxandoci, dimorando nel momento presente, ben svegli.
Senza ottenere nulla, senza andare in alcun luogo, essendo nessuno.
In questo modo sviluppiamo cinque dei sette fattori che portano all'illuminazione.
C'è naturalmente la consapevolezza.
Poi c'è la capacità, l'abilità di focalizzare la mente e di prestare attenzione.
E lo sforzo e l'energia che sono necessarie per farlo.
Una sensazione di sottofondo di calma.
E la qualità dell'equanimità.
Questo vuol dire non avere un'opinione fissa, un'idea preconcetta.
Quindi con la mente aperta.
Con il cuore che non è in uno stato di avversione o di paura.
Acquisitiveness or preference.
No greed.
Open-minded, open-hearted.
When this is established, we bring in the other two factors.
Quando questi fattori sono ben stabilizzati possiamo introdurre gli altri due.
Un senso di curiosità e l'investigazione negli insegnamenti del Buddha.
E specificamente l'impermanenza, il modo in cui creiamo la sofferenza per noi stessi e il non-sè.
Questa modalità, questo approccio è importante anche nella vita quotidiana.
La capacità di prestare attenzione a ciò che stiamo facendo.
Tutti questi fattori entrano in gioco.
Quindi ora possiamo iniziare con l'intenzione di sederci.
E possiamo cominciare a usare la tecnica della nota, dell'etichetta,
e il fatto di andare lentamente, di muoverci con lentezza.
Con delle parole molto semplici che ci permettono di portare l'attenzione con esattezza sul modo in cui ci stiamo muovendo.
Sollevare, spostare, abbassare, spingere, tirare.
L'intenzione di sedersi.
E fatelo prendendovi tutto il tempo necessario.
Assicuratevi di essere seduti comodamente.
E ancora una volta è importante assumere la posizione giusta.
La schiena dovrebbe mantenere la sua curvatura naturale, senza estendere troppo la parte inferiore della schiena, mantenendo la naturalezza della schiena.
E poi allungandosi verso l'alto dalla cima della testa, dalla sommità del capo.
Passando qualche momento per rilassarsi.
La fronte.
Gli occhi sono chiusi gentilmente.
Le labbra sono unite, ma i denti sono rilassati, sono aperti.
Spalle.
E le mani sono sulle ginocchia o comunque vi risulti più comodo.
Prendendo atto di questa postura con l'energia che sale dalla colonna e tutto il resto che è ben rilassato.
Se durante la seduta vi accorgete di tensioni, potete rilassarle.
E se vi accorgete che siete un po'
scivolati in avanti per causa della stanchezza, vi siete un po' piegati in avanti, fate un piccolo sforzo e risollevatevi.
Portando ora l'attenzione al respiro.
In questa particolare tradizione è preferibile avvertire il respiro nella zona dell'addome.
E ancora una volta possiamo usare un po' di parola di notazione solo per fermare la mente dall'avventura.
E anche qui possiamo usare una nota mentale per impedire alla mente di divagare.
Quindi quando l'addome si solleva diciamo alzare, alzare.
Non dimenticare prima perché questo ti darà l'impressione di controllare l'addome.
E non lo dite prima perché vi darebbe l'impressione di controllare il respiro.
E quando durante l'espirazione scendere, scendere.
Se invece osservate il respiro alle narici, dentro.
Fuori, fuori.
Rilassando l'attenzione portata sulle sensazioni gentili del movimento respiratorio.
Se la mente divaga, nel momento che ve ne accorgete, prendetene atto e portate l'attenzione a che cosa ha portato questo divagare.
Worrying, worrying.
Se per esempio c'è un preoccuparsi, si ripete la nota mentale preoccuparsi, preoccuparsi.
E non siamo interessati alla storia.
A cui siamo interessati è l'attitudine, è lo stato mentale.
E poi riportiamo l'attenzione al respiro.
Just resting the attention on the gentle sensations of the breath.
Allowing them to bring silence to the mind.
permettendo loro di portare silenzio alla mente.
Calma nel cuore e quiete al corpo.
Salire, scendere.
Se la mente divaga, non appena ve ne accorgete, prendete atto di ciò che state facendo.
Pianificare, programmare.
Ricordate, siamo solo interessati al mood, alle emozioni.
Ricordate che siamo interessati soltanto allo stato d'animo, all'attitudine, all'atteggiamento, all'emozione.
Se vi accorgete che sta sorgendo un po' di sonnolenza, sollevate bene la colonna.
Se volete potete aprire gli occhi.
Per lasciare che entri la luce.
Mantenendo però l'attenzione al vostro interno.
Spero che ora ti senti un po' più concentrato, concentrato.
Forse adesso siete un po' più focalizzati, più concentrati.
Quindi vedete se potete avvicinarvi un po' di più al respiro.
Vedendo se riuscite a cogliere proprio l'inizio dell'inspirazione.
È la fine dell'ispirazione, l'inizio della espirazione è la fine della espirazione.
Se mentre state facendo così vi accorgete che siete un po' tesi, questo vi rende più tesi, provate a ritirarvi dentro di voi e a ricevere le informazioni.
Provate a fare come un passo indietro al vostro interno, prendendo un po' di spazio per ricevere semplicemente l'informazione.
Sollevarsi, abbassarsi.
E se vi accorgete che la mente divaga, non appena questo accade, prendetene atto e riconoscete che cosa sta coinvolgendola.
Excitement, excitement.
Now, instead of going back to the breath, come into the body to see if you can feel it.
E adesso, in questo caso, invece di tornare al respiro, portate l'attenzione all'interno del corpo per vedere come l'avvertite a livello corporeo.
If you're having an argument with somebody, angry, angry.
Se state discutendo con qualcuno, rabbia, rabbia.
E entrate nel corpo e sentite se riuscite ad avvertirla nel corpo stesso.
Se non sentite nulla, tornate al respiro.
Se avvertite un senso di sonnolenza, di stanchezza, portate l'attenzione a quella parte del corpo dove l'avvertite maggiormente.
Potrebbe essere intorno agli occhi oppure nel petto.
E sentite.
E sentitela direttamente.
Investigate quelle sensazioni.
Ma se non sentite nulla di particolare, tornate al respiro e investigate quelle sensazioni legate al movimento respiratorio.
Rising, falling.
Sollevare, abbassare.
diventando più consapevoli del modo in cui reagiamo a ciò di cui facciamo esperienza.
Quando qualcosa è piacevole vogliamo mantenerlo, vogliamo che continui.
Quando qualcosa è spiacevole, prima cosa vogliamo ignorarlo e poi ce ne vogliamo liberare.
Questo processo di desiderio e avversione
di desiderio di volere qualcosa e di avversione è ciò che il Buddha definisce come la causa psicologica della nostra sofferenza.
È vero
diventando più consapevoli come ogni cosa sia un processo.
Tutto sorge per poi inevitabilmente scomparire.
Qualunque cosa di cui noi si stia facendo esperienza è qui soltanto per un attimo, per poi svanire.
Anche se i respiri sembrano uguali l'uno all'altro, in realtà non sono mai identici.
C'è forse qualcosa che possiate ritenere come affidabile, qualcosa a cui aggrapparvi.
diventando sempre più consapevoli di come ogni cosa di cui si fa esperienza è un oggetto.
Abbiamo scoperto dentro di noi un luogo da cui poter osservare.
E vediamo pensieri, immagini che sorgono nella mente.
Possiamo avvertire le emozioni nel cuore e le sensazioni nel corpo.
Possiamo renderci ben chiaro che si tratta tutti di oggetti della nostra consapevolezza.
C'è una distanza e una separazione tra noi e loro.
Possiamo rendercelo più chiaro usando una parola come lì.
Lì c'è un senso di malessere nella ginocchio.
There, there's an itch on the end of my nose.
C'è una prurito sulla punta del naso.
Quindi c'è da fare una distinzione tra la consapevolezza e ciò di cui la consapevolezza è consapevole.
È possibile che il percepire possa essere ciò che è percepito?
diventando più consapevoli di come tutto accade per conto proprio.
È come se noi fossimo seduti al di fuori del sistema, lasciando andare ogni controllo.
Purtuttavia la mente continua a offrire pensieri e immagini anche se non vogliamo che accada.
Il cuore ha i suoi stati d'animo, le sue emozioni.
Che noi lo si voglia oppure no.
E il corpo ha tutte le sue sensazioni, che lo si voglia oppure no.
Non c'è nulla che sia sotto il nostro diretto controllo.
Se il controllo è in un'altra parte, come può essere io?
Se il controllo è altrove, come può essere?
Come posso essere io?
Grazie.
Viene il momento in cui dobbiamo lasciare andare ogni istruzione.
Per avere una fiducia completa in questa consapevolezza intuitiva.
Questo è il Buddha within.
Questo è il Buddha interiore.
Non vuole soltanto e semplicemente osservare e sentire.
Non vuole pensare, il pensiero è un ostacolo.
Quindi limitiamoci a osservare, a sentire, a fare esperienza di tutto ciò che attira la nostra attenzione nel campo della nostra consapevolezza.
Non fate nulla e non cercate di cambiare nulla.
Quando ci avviciniamo alla conclusione di una seduta è utile riflettere un po'.
Quanto siamo stati diligenti nel riportare l'attenzione al momento presente.
Se pensiamo di aver fatto uno sforzo adeguato, possiamo congratularci con noi stessi.
Se non siamo stati troppo diligenti, dobbiamo incoraggiarci.
Senza cominciare a criticarci.
Scegliete qualcosa che è accaduto durante la seduta.
Poteva essere per esempio sonnolenza, irrequietezza, un pensiero ossessivo, qualche emozione forte.
Come l'avete gestita?
Sapevate cosa fare di fronte ad essa?
Se pensate di essere stati abili, congratulatevi con voi stessi.
Se invece pensate che potevate essere più abili, datevi un incoraggiamento.
Se non sapevate cosa fare, chiedete istruzioni a un insegnante.
Quali di queste tre caratteristiche dell'esistenza vi risultava più ovvia, più chiara?
Era forse il ruolo del desiderio, del desiderio sbagliato, il fatto di volere, di non volere.
O forse invece l'impermanenza di ogni cosa.
O che tutto era un oggetto, non sotto controllo diretto, non io, non la mia mente.
O forse che tutto era un oggetto, non sotto il mio controllo, che non si trattava, non era me, non ero io, non era mio.
E' anche buono fare una risoluzione.
Ed è anche buona cosa prendere una risoluzione.
Può essere specifica.
Per esempio, la prossima volta che mi sentirò stanco aprirò subito gli occhi.
Oppure può essere un impegno preciso per essere consapevolezza con una buona disposizione d'animo.
Aprendo ora gentilmente.
gli occhi